a possible case of illegal dumping in
the middle of the street made one
neighbor very upset and he ended up
chasing the person responsible on
Detroit's East Side with no luck and a
big mess on his hand he called us for
help Edwards tells us what happened
after he
reached we first introduced you to Jeff
Brown during seven Action News at 5 he
witnessed a man boldly dumping large
chunks of wood from a flatbed along
couch on Detroit's East Side Tuesday in
broad daylight look at all these trees
Brown says when he confronted the guy
the man took off Brown tells us he
jumped into action got into his car and
tracked down the truck he got a li D the
worst [__] John Wick the worst
equalizer number and called police but
the mess remained on the street and no
one had been caught taking action for
brown we did some digging and found ehor
dich a Warren
resident described par are you [__]
[__] me ehor
deich I wish I knew about that name
before my kids were born I would have
named him [__] eh- horse to Leah what
driveway
ehor svich claims he curb and the debris
accidentally fell out it's a little
illegal to leave the wood in the street
so what I'm asking is I'm going I you
don't have to ask me and I don't take no
orders from the woman by the
way e
Horse by the way go I
that was great just I little illegal to
leave the wood in the street so what I'm
asking is I'm going the worst sunglasses
known to man
dude arets you know arnes or whatever
you don't have to ask me and I don't
take no orders from No Woman by the way
by the way I don't take no orders from
no women dich says she was planning to
go back and clean up the wood but only
had $ but then a woman asked him to so
he's leaving it there worth of gas so
you were saying that that you were going
back to clean up the he horse the bevit
dude yes oh yes I'm I'm Mr cleanup I'm
not Mr clean a Mr Clean
Up [__]
Vaudeville I mean went on the tiptoes to
say that that last part I'm Mr Clean Up
said and I live in Warren and I'm
cleaning up Detroit go figure that one
out but somebody said that they tried to
yell at you to come back and you kept
going and it must have been a woman and
don't listen to women yelling I tell
them to shut up
well the
dude
Sader his wife left him eight months
ago well he was quite offensive with his
answers to kevich maintains he just
wants to help people remove chunks of
wood so many logs on his front
lawn I lift them all by myself with
nobody else's help old guys disabled
guys black guys white guys polish guys
Ukrainian guys and guys from Mars
also
aliens guys from Mars
also oh okay oh her oh oh okay I from
Mars from Mars yeah that's where I'm
from Mars and police are investigating
what exactly happened out here and
whether svich is responsible or whether
he'll face dude his his wife said I'm
leaving you and they got in a huge fight
and she's like oh get out she's like
you're so [__] crazy it's like you're
from Mars and like now he can't get out
over it any charges on Detroit's East
Side Tara Edwards 7 Action News claims
he hit a curb in the debris accidentally
fell out it's a little illegal to leave
the wood in the street so what I'm
asking is I'm going I you don't have to
ask me and I don't take no orders from
No Woman by the way by the way I don't
take no orders from no women she was
planning to go back and clean
I live in Warren and I'm cleaning up
Detroit go figure that one out but
somebody said that they tried to yell at
you to come back and you kept going and
there must have been a woman and I don't
listen to women yelling I tell them to
shut up well he
was the most [__] maladjusted man in
the history of of of humans you know it
was no woman that was no saying no
nobody tells me no what to do no woman
go figure that one out